israeli customers especially women are
extremely online savvy
so we have this data you know we can
look for it
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you i'm well how are you
fantastic thank you so much for for
being so generous with your time and i
know
you you have your daughters at home and
you're out of the office and and i truly
truly appreciate it i have so much to
learn from you with your
experience in in all different companies
but most recently now in super farm
running their brand development and
thinking of of the next
of the next brands that the customers
want right right
incredible okay so so you know for for
those that are perhaps in in
california and not in tel aviv right now
super farm is is one of israel's largest
pharmacy chain
it's like the regular cvs and walgreens
that we have here
where you go in and you have both super
farm items but you also have
an abundance of other brands in the
store that it's like a go-to place so
shiran before we dive
into super farm and you work there give
me a little bit of background into
who you are and and sort of the journey
that you've that you've gone through to
get
to to the role that you're at today
i actually stumbled upon it um by
chance uh i was living in new york doing
my master's
uh at the new school and i was looking
for an internship which
uh internships if it's not like google
or microsoft are not very big in israel
so when i went to
ibc i was just a waitress you know
you know work to make a living and to
pay their end
uh but uh when i moved to new york it
was obviously a great
amazing opportunity to be a part of
great companies
um so i actually was working
in the um hospitality industry
like events and um
clubs basically someone uh
someone who knew someone in uh in revlon
uh got me an interview um i was accepted
i was a masters
student along with lots of um
like college girls
but but still it turned out uh quite
okay because they i
i stayed there for a while after so i
was uh
a part of the product development team
by the way was that a
it was was that a turn off or was that
was that difficult to go
into a u.s based internship where
a lot of the a lot of people that are
are college students
that are that are much younger than you
well first of all i was quite yeah i
mean i was only 25
it's not like i was like in my 30s or
something uh
and and i didn't really mind because
they were all a part of the pr
team and i was in the product
development team so i had a different
position
and different things to do uh later then
i
actually joined this pr team as uh just
to work there for a few months as well
and then i moved to another company so
actually i mean i always loved brands
also you know food wise and in general
i always found it uh interesting also as
a little girl
um and i also won what is it brand give
me give me your
your insight in like you know a
two-minute lecture what
it what constitutes a brand in
the 21st century i feel like it's mostly
an emotion
uh or something that makes you feel
something
um you know i for me not not because i
work there but super farm
is like the strongest brand for me as
being a woman being in my 30s being a
mother
and um it was always a feeling for me
even back when i was 16
back when i was a soldier you know
because this
retailer this chain this like their logo
and everything
um walks with you through your life
um but i can also think of brands you
know obviously like glossier
that make you feel
special that make you feel uh that that
it that are like making you feel unique
and they have to do with
how you feel about yourself how you
position yourself so i think
they are first of all emotions and
second they are tools
to identify and differentiate yourself
in
in in your in society among other people
um especially today especially when
talking to
gen zetters it's all about how you
differentiate
yourself what what does using or
purchasing or uh wearing a brand
tells about you um what does it say
when you post on your instagram that you
shop something or did you support your
brand or you just support it
right right so it's mostly about
um self-identification differentiation
for yourself right as a persona an
emotion
i love it okay so so let's transition
now to to what you're doing today
so you've had your experience revlon
you've also had your experience with
within a packaging company right that
distributes
beauty products they they make package
development like they work with everyone
with the entire l'oreal group with estee
lauder group with chanel now
she said with everyone and i learned a
lot there you know
working with mac and with bobby brown
and with all the big names
uh obviously it was again i was
i was uh i was a writer after school so
i took whatever they
they gave me and you know it started
with running errands
for everyone and sitting in the
messenger center with everyone and
i did it with much love and dedication
and it taught me a lot um but then
i decided along with my husband to come
back here to israel because we wanted to
start a family and in new york obviously
it's not even relevant
money wise so we came back here and i
worked for four years in um
april cosmetics which is like a
specialty
beauty uh it's more like on the
selective higher end
tier um and two a bit more than two and
a half years ago i moved to super farm
which was
like a dream come true for me super farm
for me
it's for retail it's like it's google
really
yeah yeah so give me you know
just give me the context a little bit
into the the israeli ecosystem and where
superform is located within that because
i think it's important for the remainder
of the conversation to understand
the incredible work you're doing within
superform to understand how big super
farm is and how it integrates into the
lives of every israeli but it's actually
not just israelis but
it's also abroad right uh first of all
israel is a tiny country it's only nine
million people and super power is 260
doors
so it's literally everywhere it's
uh a 10 minute drive from every
israeli's house
basically every israeli's house yeah
it's it's in the radius of everyone's
it's in neighborhoods and malls and
it's everywhere it's the largest it's
the leading and largest health and
beauty
retailer here in israel it has
its private label is huge and because we
have those capabilities manufacturing
shipping logistic capabilities we
decided two and a half years ago
to also operate as a distributor so we
also work directly with brands
not manufacturers that create the live
brand for us or private label but
retailer brands that we can um
that we negotiate with and then decide
to uh
to launch them directly without a
middleman without a distributor in the
middle we operate both as a retailer and
distributor
for them um and this is
what we only we carry brands that we
feel and we know that
the israeli customer is looking for
okay shiran what is the israeli customer
looking for what like
this sounds like such a like you know a
difficult
question that you're sitting and you
have to you're looking at a party and
you're saying
hey can i can i imagine a million people
buying this yes or no it
it sounds so you know i'm coming as an
engineer from very scientific background
and i need everything to be quantifiable
in numbers but
you can you can never quantify something
like this right
first of all we i mean israeli customers
especially women are
extremely online savvy so we have this
data you know we can look for it we know
we have complete we have online
competition
we see which brands they follow on
instagram
we see which brands they discuss on
facebook groups
uh we ask questions we have our teams in
260 doors telling us which brands
they're asking
uh uh to purchase to buy um
so we we have a we have a decent clue
but on the other hand we're also looking
for we're looking for newness we're
looking for
innovation uh which is a bit you know
it's a different
it's a different term when we're talking
about skincare or beauty because
it's quite it's quite um challenging to
to create newness in these fields
um so we
basically i would not launch a brand
that no one here knows
because i would not want to waste time
or money on market education i rather
have
brands that people already purchase
online from abroad
or big names that everyone know um
and if it's a new brand i'd rather
develop a brand myself you know if it's
an unknown brand i rather create a brand
of my own
uh like we did already with three
different ones
uh and then you educate the market but
you have a higher gp
you have the ability to control the
materials you create them from scratch
so i would say for your question we're
looking for
brands that are very instagram oriented
again uh because instagram is a key
factor in my decision making process um
and we're looking for brands obviously
with good quality
not necessarily um um expensive like
the price here the customers here are
very price savvy
um yeah and for me an agenda we only
launch um brands that allow us to offer
the
products for the uh same prices country
of origin
like if i'm launching a uk brand price
would be
the same if a customer would buy it when
she visits london
or if it's an american brand same thing
um and you know we always have
competition like i
i buy my beauty products on asos and i
have a discount code it's il17 to every
israeli girl here knows it
so it's um so we always have competition
and sometimes you can buy the products
for a lower price but still it's um
i feel it's decent and we were being
honest and decent
when we and we offered the goods in a
good price so it's both pricing
and and portfolio so choose like choices
that we need to make
so it sounds like you have an awesome a
playground because you have an idea for
a new brand that you want to develop
you might get an idea that from from
some competition you say well actually i
think i can do better i can do
cheaper with better materials and with
my own branding and you mentioned you've
already gone through this adventure
a few times and launching this brand to
260 doors
first thing you want to you want to
create a new brand and you want to test
it to the market
shiran what do you do like walk me
through this life cycle of bringing this
to fruition because it sounds like what
you got to play around with
uh sounds like successfully it's
something that a lot a lot of people you
know i'm watching i love watching shark
think it sounds like that's what every
shark tank
pitch person does right thinking of a
brand and but
and you get to you know think through it
with the team and launch it already in
260 stores yeah
first of all it's uh a lot of fun you
know skiing here beauty in general it's
it's it is a playground especially for
but i think you have to have a
a professional background you know my
husband told me
when we were i think 24
uh be a professional just choose when
when we were deliberating should i take
this
internship he told me i would i mean if
you
if you go for it you this is your path
like become a professional and sense
that this is like the best tp ever gave
me
and since then i am you know i read all
researchers
i i i actually share every share it with
people
uh at my workplace like this is my turf
beauty industry global trends uh
so i think first of all you have to be a
professional what you do like not
everyone can create a beauty brand
second thing um you do for me
anyway we we're looking for the relevant
trends
and we create a mood board like we have
our references we see
uh in our we have tons of data obviously
in super farm so we're looking for the
uh the brands to tell the most the
specific products that we're looking for
it's it's
it's mostly like a business
administration network you know things
you learn is cool
uh but in general if i'm if i'm thinking
marketing wise
we're looking i'm creating a mood board
i'm talking to a designer
um i choose the right assortment you
have to be very accurate i never go
uh i never develop products that are
already that we already have in our
portfolio
um it's always newness um and
mostly when we work on a brand or
when we choose a brand it's um i i
mostly think about how does the customer
feel like who is my customer
and how does she want to feel when she
purchases uh a product of this brand
how long does this process take from and
set from this idea that you have for a
new cosmetic pro
product to when i sit to 260 stores
today you can
do it in four months five months you can
obviously
sometimes it will look we had we have
longer projects but i feel like this is
a reality today
um if you look at influencers and you
know a lot of like
very small niche brands that are being
created from scratch now
um it's not like back then when
processes were way longer you can
develop
with a designer with a factory with
you know on instagram you can build a
brand quite quickly
um you know there's registration and you
know formulations but
if you have if you work with existing
formulas or you just
upscale them a bit um it doesn't take
long this is the reality now you know
people get famous in a second
and then they create their own brands in
a second
and you know you go to sleep the next
day wake up you have
three new brands especially in the
beauty industry
so we have to work fast because we have
competition
yeah so so what is like the hardest
thing about this job so
is that the ideation phase is the
competition
the the analytics and and understanding
what's happening
i think um choosing the right assortment
um making sure the customers are happy
uh
and i think the most challenging thing
is to to well
well obviously if you know it you are
you can make a lot of money it's just
knowing what the customer is looking for
uh for me working in super farm
i mean i'm a 33 year old mother of three
so i am the ideal super farm customer
you know personal care for toiletries
for diapers for everything
but for beauty you know there's a whole
crowd out there
of 12 16 18 year olds
i'm not them and i have to sell them
what they're looking for
and you know sometimes they're half my
age or wait
or less and i need to know what you're
looking for and this is a big challenge
distance for me is the most challenging
um uh thing because you don't want to be
pathetic you know you don't want to try
and sell young and i'm only 33 it's not
like i'm 60
right but you know i see my i have a
daughter she's five and a half
and she is interested in in specific
products she and her friends you know so
this might be maybe an easier age but a
16 year old
which has money and she is she's able to
purchase whatever she wants and she's
willing to spend money
for me it's quite challenging and i
think it's relevant to all
i mean not not only the beauty of
toiletries uh industry it's in every
industry also in fashion
also like in general exactly you know
i'm
i'm i'm coming to stanford at 24 and all
of my classmates are using tech talk
i have no idea what this platform is
about and why people would want to look
at 15 second videos
i'm starting to get it but it's a
different mentality but so sean how do
you compensate for that because you you
have the responsibility of selling to
this demographic as well
right and you need to be you need to be
an expert on it just as much as you're
an expert on
on the 33 year old young mothers in
israel so
how do you go and study what do 16 year
olds want and what do 22 year olds want
well super farm obviously you know we
have a lot of researchers
and uh you know groups and we have
you know agencies that get money for it
uh right but
i i i'd rather be ahead of trend
and not you know the pathetic thing is
coming in the end
because the research is always in
hindsight it's not it's not necessarily
forecasting
you know i'm not on tick-tock obviously
uh but i'm trying to you know i'm trying
to identify trends
through style side uh siding and trend
forecasting
platforms and and through instagram
instagram is
like it's the strongest most important
tool for me
um this is this is the key to everything
i always think if a brand is
instagramable
now we also think about it in tik tok um
but you know we're trying to find
additional ways we ask questions we know
this if it's
if it's a an older crowd we can also see
we can also use
facebook groups uh but for the
challenging group of
of of gen z um
it it's a problem i'm i'm telling you
the truth you know i have a brand
one of our my brands uh has like a
skincare
like a roller a rose quartz roller which
is very big on instagram well it was for
the last two weeks two years i recently
found out girls that are 10 and 11 are
purchasing this product they don't need
it
okay but it it looks
good on camera so they they buy it wow
that's fascinating what is one thing
that you learned about brands
that you didn't know before you joined
super farm what is like one insight
you've gained over the past few years
that you're like oh i'm starting to
understand what this whole brand thing
is about
that you can create emotional
connection to a brand um quite quickly
if you're accurate um and that
bit well globally business-wise i feel
like
big brands that i was raised on than all
women in
in like globally all the women in the
world
were always you know we always looked at
estee lauder clinique
lancome basically um a lot of
uh french brands you know friends was
like the
empire of beauty they became they got
like this insulting insulting
um title um of legacy brands
and you know they are starting to look
very uncool to young ladies um
and i learned like that it doesn't
really matter how much money you have
uh because the moment you might i mean
you might lose it anyway so
it has to do with making right choices
it doesn't you know estee lauder for
example two years ago
they started uh working with or maybe
three years ago already they
they took kendall jenner and put her in
the front in order to speak to gen z
it didn't really help i feel because
they use the same products like a serum
that is nearly 500 shekels like 100
or something and got her to wear a red
suit like who wears a red suit so
it's talking to older women again
using a younger uh ambassador
so i it doesn't really matter how much
money you have we have small niche
brands that sephora take and make them
explode
because they're accurate right right
speak to the
the customers of tomorrow the customers
that they're looking for now they
already have the 50
60 year old women by there they don't
have that
they don't necessarily have the 16 year
olds
right shiran this was a incredibly
insightful thank you for your time and
generosity and i know you have
kids in the other room so really say
thank you for thank you for taking the
time to do this i really appreciate it
before we leave i need three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i am in
impatience
i am
this is a hard one this is the hardest
question of all
yeah i don't really have patience i
think
i listen
okay yeah i i listen and pay attention
to
comments from that makes a lot of sense
yeah
and i i multitask
i i'm a great believer in don is better
than perfect you know since i was
sent honestly not not sounding like a
cliche
i read leaning and i took this
well it's not her sentence obviously but
i
took it and this is my way of life um
i rather finish most um
most tasks in a 90
way instead of holding back on one
specific i'm not a perfectionist let's
just say that
um so i think two very important tips
are
finish what you started even if it's not
perfect
just get it over with and move over to
your next
task and and be a professional
dive in know what you're talking about
become an expert
and that's it thank you very very much
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you bye
hmm